[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
how you don't have a latino on yeah i'm
the [ __ ] los angeles lakers
i know well you know what here 99 of
your offense is of your audience of your
fans are latinos i know well i want to
see [ __ ] hector out there they're
shooting a nine-pointer bro yeah you
know wearing [ __ ] dickies though yeah
you know and converses
and he [ __ ] only gets to shoot nine
points cigarettes in his ears yeah
yeah but that should be beautiful some
people tell me i look like ben affleck
some people tell me i look like ben
stiller yeah big difference you look
like ben better i know that yeah
yeah yeah dude so i thought
you look like somebody who's [ __ ]
using performance enhancing drugs to
swim
you look like like it would be
it would be shocking to me that a guy
that looks like you isn't using crystal
meth like i'd be i'm in shock that
you're not why because there's not a
t-shirt under the sweater what because
it's just sweater-to-skin it's a sweater
to skin yeah and really like and just
like the hair and the beard it's like
it's like you just look like kind of
beard well whatever like a little bit
you know he's got like a civil war head
you know what i mean
it just looks like like you use drugs to
like get through your pain you know what
i mean so i would think so i so
definitely like rob in a liquor store is
what you love you have that rob in a
liquor store look you also look like you
could be like you're you're a suspect
you look like you're in any making a
murderer [ __ ] like you're on the list
for sure you're on the shortlist so i
would say one of those either a murder
suspect or rob in a bank but i think
like an actual crime you could actually
do like with who you are as theo not on
drugs like la like as theo vaughn right
now so i think you i could see you
um being being a distracted driver
texting and kill a mentally challenged
person that's what i could see you doing
and then leaving the scene of the
accident oh yeah i could see you doing
that and then do i leave with them do i
put them in the back of my car yeah and
then as an attempt to cover yeah like
you need to raise them at home exactly
oh but that's a good move but you could
look but you could lose a sponsor for
that yeah yeah you may lose an ad but
what about years later when i
reintroduced him to society and he
didn't [ __ ] dance yeah i mean it's
like like that movie nell remember that
movie yeah i was just raised by wolf and
that's the song at the end if i asked
you to dance and it's me wheeling him
out into a gymnasium yeah dude his
parents haven't seen him for years and
they're not even excited to see him yeah
and i wheel him out there and he gets up
and just would you say
so
tonight talking bee and then he [ __ ]
just pirouettes here yeah
that's beautiful that's the crime i
could see you doing yeah yeah what am i
making two gay guys in the stands just
hold a lighter up yeah it's like chill
out fellas you know yeah this boy is
mine you got nice fingers too i know i
know that's one of those things i've
never said to you but i've been i've
been watching your ig for a long time
and i've been friends with you i think
since
2013-14 and you got some of the nicest
fingers in the game and toes i didn't
realize that you're because you're
wearing thong toe sandals right now so
you got toes yeah i'd like to put
mustard on your toes and ketchup on your
fingers
and take a bite out of your hot dog is
thong toad sandals is that too much for
is that like a woman kind of wearing a
thong or what is that like
you came out if you i'll be honest with
you if you came to my part of brooklyn
right with the thong toe sandals like
that there's a chant not when you're
with me but there's a chance like you
know one of my boys names pat finnegan
patty fly balls he would hit you with a
taped up wiffle ball bat just because he
would think like why is this dude coming
out with his nose socks on yeah so you
got a guy an adult doing freaking
the wor lamest crime ever bro yeah what
the hell are you gonna do he would take
are you gonna rob a bank with a
slingshot
he used to tape quarters and nickels to
the end of a tape a whiffable bat and
then put tape around and just hit people
in the back of the head with it and you
say
you just get lit up by pouting my balls
do you dress nice when you fly do you
dress plus i got a little penis you know
that i've never seen your penis dude
what i've never sent you my dick i've
never seen that one that i wouldn't put
that i will block you if you send me it
i got one i thought i sent you one i'm
gonna stay off porn i'm 43 days right
now i i um i i i got one where you know
i send it out as my dick but it's
actually just a television remote in my
sweatpants but it looks like i have a
[ __ ] hog and when girls ask for a
dick pic that's what i send out
and they think like
they think i have the biggest dick ever
and then when we finally do get to sex
you know i got to turn all the lights
off and get them as wet as possible
suddenly it's the uh it's the um apple
tv remote suddenly you got
yeah you think it's files
yeah i mean a lot is this fire stick
what is this little do you want to say
look i do not okay all right because it
looks like a i mean it looks like a
hammer really yeah dude like what kind
of you said like a small hammer it looks
like well it's just it's just a thick
it's a television remote in gray
sweatpants but it looks like my dick
right it's easily and i've sent it
around it's women i sent it well if they
asked me i sent it to women and then and
then i sent it to my boys my boys have
it so there's a circulation that's ever
that's my cruise dick pic i do not want
to be one of your boys a podcast is like
hey i'm you know me now right so it's
like i'm listening to you you're in my
ear for an hour it almost feels like a
family member i think to some people i
know even me when i listen to podcasts
sometimes to catch up with you guys i'll
listen to your guys podcast because i'm
like they're i'm can find out about
their life this way yeah so and i think
that easily makes an audience member buy
a ticket what i need to do personally is
stop divulging so much personal
information because i'm pissing members
of my family and friends off because i'm
making jokes about them using their real
names because i just get so in the
moment because right now we're just a
little sad i think that with my whole
town yeah because right now we're just
like in a little beautiful studio but
like this could be heard by a million
plus and i'm just yelling pat finnegan
that's his actual birth name that's his
government name and he's an active duty
firefighter and i just said he used to
beat people with a bat yeah he could
lose his job well look or he could gain
work somewhere as a bouncer latinos
never complain really no latinos are
gonna hopefully yeah
yeah take over the world bro yeah and i
would happily say
because you know that's why i deserve it
that's why i have a puerto rican
daughter man i'm i've [ __ ] gotten
that [ __ ] early man i did it for my
career 100 because you know i'm a
straight white male we're very easily
hateable and i look like a tiki torch
you know what i mean i look like the
problem like i'm an undercover cop so my
puerto rican daughter man it's like what
are you going to say to me now i'm like
[ __ ] i got my baby puerto rican girl
yeah you know you look like definitely
like a guy that works at the church that
gets busted like a church pastor but the
shady yeah you know i look like
somebody's ex yeah i look like i look
like somebody's ex-husband
you look like definitely every
ex-husband in a lifetime movie like you
you know you're dating this girl you
love her and she's like oh i have a kid
with this guy and it's a [ __ ] let
down you're like oh [ __ ] i got a dude
this guy's got to be a part of my life
yeah yeah yeah you should carry a lunch
pail
you see that guy on barstool with the
third gear fart uh-uh yeah something to
look up what far do you think the farts
are getting nastier in certain countries
or not i think yeah well i think that's
why i think we need a wall
is because i think you know outside the
united states
those farts man that's the reason i
every time trump's like we need a wall
i'm like yeah mexicans [ __ ] are
dirty look at that and canadian assets
too man don't sleep on canadian uh don't
sleep on how disgusting canadian fart
could be poutine you know what that's
like that's cheese curd yeah i want a
wall around all that because there's a
wall around us man why why don't
everybody should just get a little wall
that they can bring with them and put
wherever they want canada and mexico
because the truth of the situation here
we got a man right here doing something
there's a bourbon guy right here this is
the
ain't never hear a fart hit third gear
as the couch okay take a look
gonna and they're gonna blame it somehow
on white people i'm sure dude that's
insane
insane right wow
drift huh dude i was watching that thing
for an hour yesterday crying
my beautiful four-year-old daughter was
doing ballet and doing some of the
finest moves she's ever done and get
into new heights in her life and i was
head buried in the phone crying laughing
because of this dude's third gear fart
and her mom was like this is why we
can't be together her mom was just was
like this is why i'm just always going
to be called parents
because because i was just like yo
crying she thought i was crying first my
kids mom thought i was crying because
how beautiful my daughter nailed the
pirouette i was listening to that my
headphones on you
are they husband and wife yes they are
yeah he just blasted his wife with that
oh could you imagine what those undies
must look like
oh his draws must be
wild good hair bro i do yeah dude i just
[ __ ] wish i could grow my [ __ ] out
like that
i can't though bro you i wonder how you
would look with long hair you know i
would [ __ ] have it didn't you have a
ponytail somebody said no never bro
you used to work on like on one of those
like um
like daytime cruise boats yeah in
jamaica
dude you know what we should do meaning
we should do a like a boxing match for
charity and the winner has to get the
other guy's haircut
yeah
yeah you gotta come up with this [ __ ]
[ __ ] i will never do a boxing master
charity it's a great way to end your
career
yeah it's like hey they always set you
up against somebody who's gonna beat
your ass yeah maybe in the state's the
biggest place right you move tickets
brother but it was crazy man and it was
amazing you know everybody that came out
and stuff but
oh wow
that was a call i called that a top of
the cracker that came out right out of
the top of my ass track
sometimes it's interesting sometimes a
fart is really right on deck and then
sometimes it's very lost and it's kind
of like almost like they have to call it
to the front of the line like its mom
just got there to pick it up at carpool
and it's like hey where's ronnie yeah
that came out atop my ass so i didn't
even mean to time it that way but it was
one of those things where i can't hold
it anymore it's going to find a way out
and it leaked out at the top
bro remember we used to fight on opie
you ever seen those fights on opie when
he said i look dutch and then i told him
he looked like eileen wuernos the first
female serial killer
i was actually i was actually looking at
the comments on these youtube successful
female serial killers yeah i was looking
at the comments once oh my god dude i
was getting [ __ ] crushed by your fans
yeah well they hated me bro hated me did
they oh my god they were like this
[ __ ] bum
they were cr bro you literally won that
fight in head that's afraid to go all
the way bro i'm talking about like if
you look at the first 100 comments 80 95
of them like theo rocks
five and then five of them like chris is
good but he still seems he still sounds
deaf
you said i look like a deaf guy that
goes to the gym oh dude you're hilarious
you look like a deaf leper yeah now
everybody else now opie and carl and
charlotte are all dead oh you look like
the strongest deaf person ever
dude if you were real real quiet yeah
and entered a contest for the strongest
person yeah
you would win but here's the problem you
would [ __ ] it up bro
you'd want to tell a joke and then your
hair i remember you didn't have a hat or
and i said your hair looked like the
michigan state spartan helmet
and then
i remember that and then you told me
and then you know you said to me that
was so [ __ ] funny you said you said
dude if you if you could meet yourself
you would hate it there up yeah
dude that was epic [ __ ] that was a dope
fight damn i do look like that [ __ ] no
not anymore
not anymore you look you fine now son
you're fine girl really
i want to ask brad but i kind of
chickened out is because the thing is
like they all kind of look alike to me
little people so i was kind of one to be
like brad like you know brad looks
different he's you know famous and doing
well but like all the other ones like
all these little pictures it's like i
don't know
it's all the same to me well dude i
respect them all but i just you know
what i don't respect them i do i respect
them all
i keep my distance safely and i respect
them all wow i'll tell you this i saw
two cats attack a uh attack a little
person in hermosa beach
and this is about seven years ago
probably about 11 years ago now i saw
two cats attack a little person in
hermosa dude and it was insane bro it
was like rome it was like watching
ancient rome go really yeah i kissed a
little woman on the lips yeah like a
couple years ago made out after the show
beautiful beautiful spirit beautiful
soul and uh was that in where baltimore
that was not in baltimore that was
actually outside bananas comedy club oh
over there
yep i made out with a little little girl
not a little girl
[Laughter]
a little woman
i made out with a little person who was
a legally aged woman in her 20s damn
what an ironic name for the city hasbro
heights yeah there you go nikki bangs
i could see you being like a obviously
you seem like a dude that works at a
toll booth that [ __ ] already tells
people he's going to do something
different like on your lunch break you
tell all the black ladies you're going
to be doing something different but you
still keep coming back yeah and you
always pocket a couple of quarters you
think you have a scheme it's like
stealing like 75 cents a day yeah and
stacking it up at home for like a big
adventure yeah i live with my mother for
sure
atlantic city yeah so petty crime like
that 75 cents a day crime i could see
you doing yeah um what else
i could see you uh
going into the air force i could see you
doing some like a wall type of [ __ ]
right right yeah like going rogue going
to another country going to afghanistan
or saddam um doing some [ __ ] like that
insane yeah or somewhere iraq and just
like because like because i just want to
defend freedom and defend my country i'm
killing innocent women and children yes
i'm in the middle east yeah some dirty
homeland type yeah yeah next thing
you're over there in a [ __ ] sweat
lodge yeah just drinking curry through a
straw isis gets me to try i got but i
got such a big head i just keep [ __ ]
up there beheading videos yeah i got
like a size eight hat head i could see
you yeah getting in a lawsuit with new
era hats because they don't have a
proper fit yo i got a big ass head man
you're dutch aren't you yeah no i'm not
dutch i actually i thought my whole life
i was italian in german like every other
you know white piece of [ __ ] on the east
coast but i found that i'm like 70
german wow yeah mostly german so you
were kind of right a little while yeah
that's all right i tell my mom i'm like
hey do you want to come with us to
germany um i want to take my daughter to
germany and you could come through i'll
buy you a plane ticket you know you can
babysit or whatever when i go out and
get these german guys you know brothels
or whatever late night and um and my mom
goes no we're not going to go to germany
let's go to disney world and if you want
to go to germany we could just go to
epcot and go to the german country and
we can have some beers because she's
four years old why are you taking her to
germany i'm like
this is my idea i just want to show her
christmas she was like she's too young
she's not gonna have a good time so my
mother convinced me to go to disney so
we go to disney here's the thing so
first of all that the trip starts off
disney world starts off poorly because i
had i i um i just come off great runner
shows at gotham comedy club beautiful
new york city great my hometown chris
mozillia christmas silly legend great
shows
and every time i pee it's burning it's
burning i got a little sting so i'm like
ah [ __ ] what have you been having sex
with random women i've been having
unprotected sex yep so i'm just like for
months before that you know i probably
had unprotected sex about 40 plus women
wow yeah yeah so that's they don't call
me chrissy dripdrop for nothing
so i've since improved but you know bro
no
ain't afraid to get you know just to be
a human crissy drip drop baby taking
chances bro yeah so so anyway so the
trip is going good first of all you know
you're in about ten thousand dollars to
have you know your mother and your
daughter go you're in about it's about
10 g's
so first day we get there we go to the
magic kingdom and you get there and all
they do is pride themselves all disney
world does is pride themselves on
how it
how friendly they are to the uh nature
economy how do you say that how they're
um
what they're uh eco-friendly they're
eco-friendly so they're saying they use
paper straws all we do is use paper
straws you love us paper straws
then i take my daughter to get her hair
done at the bippity boppity boutique
which is the boutique in the magic
kingdom 600 [ __ ] dollars no way to
get her hair done an extra would you get
it done into dude a hot air balloon
i got it done into nick's bangs it was
about six hundo
you know so 600 600 to get her done with
the prince she got a cinderella dress
she got her hair done by cinderella so
it's a whole experience and then and
then extra 50 bucks for tea i saw them
making the tea at a [ __ ] keurig oh
yeah in the back so [ __ ] so it's
like okay
paper straws you're using paper straws
you'll save the turtles but you'll rape
you'll rape the [ __ ] parents right so
all [ __ ] up so i was pissed off
because my mother had my credit card
because i was taking i was on my phone a
lot responding to emails you know
sexting i was in a full sex hole and
work hole while my daughter and mother
are experiencing these beautiful things
at disneyland so i'm just sorry you're
like i'm just fully out of my mind right
oh yeah yeah so i'm being an idiot
so my mother's like listen why don't you
i will meet you back here in two hours
give me your credit card and then my uh
see my amex just getting [ __ ] hit up
what are they doing
getting tathy caricature yeah my mom my
mom got shirts you know that wild
western drawing pictures fake gun y'all
was gone for two hours she hit my corner
for 2 300 kids ash
yeah and i just was like [ __ ] so then
i'm like because then i got stressed out
when you get stressed down you have
chlamydia on deck when you have std
brewing when you get stressed out it
really starts to flow
so i was like [ __ ] i know i have it so i
call my boy who's an er doctor and i
explained to him the signs and symptoms
he was like [ __ ] hey drop off a bag of
salt over here yo yo
he was like that's an std man how quick
can you get back to new york new york i
said this is day one of my disney trip
we're at the magic kingdom he goes all
right send me your location so i sent
him the location he sent gets a pharmacy
like whatever 10 miles away but in
orlando still still kind of like on the
outskirts of disney like a oh not in
disney no no but like on the not on the
disney property but like where disney
people who work for disney like their
local cvs okay so goes out there calls
in the std [ __ ] medication for me so
i go there i'm swaying this everyone's
got little kids you know sore throat
medicine people buying binky everyone's
got little chems too
and i'm over there and i go i go over
there and i pick up std medication i had
a goofy shirt on i swear i had a goofy
shirt on and i left disney hat on and i
forgot
because i was dressed you know my my
daughter was like you gotta dress wear
your disney [ __ ] yeah so i picked up std
men i took them my daughter and mother
back to the hotel i said hey listen i'm
just gonna go for a jog and i got an
uber and i went and picked up those std
meds with my goofy shirt on and i popped
those and then i started to feel better
started to feel a little bit better and
now i'm proud to say that i've been
chrissy condoms i was chrissy celibacy
for a month after that now i've been
exclusively chrissy condoms
[Music]
ain't no right way just the wrong way
[Music]